1 ce disque avec moi embauché à contrat
on part pour faire tous les postes de la
sûreté du québec la région mais sur le
territoire ce qui me les avait tous fait
aujourd'hui j'en ai fait monsieur usées
conduire pour aller dans tous les
endroits vous avez un poste de police le
témiscamingue qui fait affaire avec tous
les algonquins de témiscamingue à cause
des propos des deux sphères impose aux
prises en abitibi j'étais juste un coup
de joie dans le grand nord j'étais
partout et j'ai fait la tournée complète
déjà sauté du québec qui cherchait un
anthropologue pour sensibiliser les
policiers aux réalités autochtones dans
le contexte la guerre du saumon l'acquis
souvient d'ailleurs du saumon 1979 1980
les premières nations font des
revendications les premières nations
commencent à se manifester on est dans
la révolution tranquille des premières
nations depuis 1900 sont des six ont ils
ont eut ils ont réclamé leurs droits
leur territoire des traités plus revu la
convention de la baie james
mais là ça fait dix ans il arrive avec
le dossier somme on est étonné moi je
travaille j'ai beaucoup travaillé dans
ma vie le village innu de meg et quan
chi une rivière qui s'appelle un bien
maigre
je vis on l'a chanté ya pas de boulot
soit rivermead on serait surpris l'as
bram que de puissantes l'isi nous n'avez
pas droit de pêcher un saumon un saumon
sur la rivière ils étaient campés l'été
sur près de la rivière mais il était
interdit de saumon près c'était réservé
aux américains ou mais j'irai aux
pêcheurs sportifs
on est dans une situation de grandry
grande injustice aresti gauche
on parle là cascapédia la matapédia de
toutes les grandes rivières à saumon du
côté de la baie des chaleurs
les pêcheurs commerciaux ont tous les
droits
les pêcheurs sportifs ont tous les
droits les mecs mac arrive en dernier
comme dit si rock yvon grébille et les
normands qui resteront peut-être dans
clinique max
se soulèvent bête défilaient dans la
rivière se chicane avec les ministères
vous rendez vous et que du québec gros
dos sur toute une vie dans ce temps là
je vous conduis dans ce temps l'homme on
haïssait les autochtones c'est à dire
qu'on trouve à quitter béchir au lieu
des chroniqueurs de chaussée pas je les
avais et soudainement le ministère
ordonne que la police intervienne à
restigouche mans à lever les filets là
c'est une grosse communauté listé gauche
big mac
il ya des armes partout c'est déjà ça
ils sont armés pour faire la guerre mais
quand même ils ont des fusils qui ont
des carabines et à 350 policiers
complète
on a frôlé la catastrophe
elie médias internationaux ont couvert
la chose il y avait le pont templeton
n'y avait que des femmes là dessus il ya
eu on n'y a pas eu de mort on a passé
proche
finalement c'était la répétition
générale de ce qui allait se passer dix
ans plus tard au corps puis quand la
crise d'oka est arrivé les personnes qui
souffrent d'un stigmate
merci gauche là il ya trois intervention
policière massive
on aurait pu on aurait pu déraper mais
les policiers s'en sont sortis de là
puis à quelqu'un qui est l état major en
mourir puisqu'on te fais tu le sais
qu'ici je ne sais quoi en ce moment
c'est quoi un filet environ ont été
houleux sur quelle planète
le deal intervenir dans le cpo d'un coin
c'est qu'il est bon c'est qu'il est
méchant donc et policiers étaient
obligés d'assister au évolué renseigner
quoi je faisais l'histoire complète des
autochtones de christophe colomb jusqu'à
la convention de vienne
je commençais avec christophe colomb
pourquoi y est venu puis ctek east gold
puis qu'est-ce que les espagnols ont
fait payer ça durait 14 et c'était
magistral ce n'est pas une discussion
c'était un magistral de 14 ans et c'est
ce qu'elle est sûre tu es ce que vous
avez demandé parce que je comprends
c'est au début et la game ce moment il
ya une crise mais après ce que j'allais
faire une carte blanche mais je il me et
me sais que c'est comme si
s'immobilisait des patrouilles arts en
général ils étaient ils si molly
m'immobiliser patrouilleurs pendant deux
jours en uniforme
il était devant moi puis je l'avais
pendant deux jours puis à la fin
l'objectif c'était de le revoir les yeux
puis dakar et les oreilles et le mar
garde évidemment ça fait on savait pas
ça 2 on voit pas les choses a même
manière et tour on est donc sensibilisé
à cette réalité l'heure parce que
normalement aux autres samarie mais
c'est vrai que ça va ça rien ils seront
déléguées il reste un jeune homme il ya
19 ans il y avait tant aidé en sûreté du
québec le contrat de sûreté du québec
c'est que tu es tout c'était québec t de
lotbinière tettey de montréal mais
dispose aller partout ce territoire
qu'en général quand les gens n'y vont
poster et hotmail sur un poste très
éloignées star va avait le mérite au
témiscamingue pilote tu travailles tu as
des indiens par tous et qui sait à
vienne
ils sortent d'où s'étaient alors comment
ça se fait que c'est comme ça pourquoi
il ya des lois spéciales pourquoi y ait
des réserves il sape aussi les
algonquins s'imposer quoi l'aider tout
est question d'alcool les conditions
sociales d'où viennent les conditions
sociales d'un coup ils travaillent en
général on parle de ce genre mais si je
vous dis que il ya eu des cas maniwaki à
7 celle à schefferville
comment voyez vous pourriez allonger la
liste jusqu'à via une sorte de zone
d'impunité vous êtes d'abord en région
isolée
vous avez des
des postes qui sont pas couverts par les
médias qui sont pas couverts par les
journalistes ya très peu de une omerta
policière il ya une sorte de fatalité
finalement qui est acceptée c'est dur à
faire sortir quand on le fait sortir
hans zimmer dont on suit personne
personne n'a réagi personnes au 10 mai
celle hors cac c'est là que je vienne
blessés je sais pas quoi dire là dessus
c'est notre société comme ça on est
capable de faire ça tabou de battre à
bout de ces jeux
c'est comme me poser la question si vous
pensez que j'ai fait ça pendant 25 ans
pour rien parce que là vous l'avez fait
pendant l'été comme vous le faites plus
depuis moins de dix ans les gens auprès
de la sûreté du québec
je ne fais plus de plus de 10 à ce
qu'ils désirent que les jeunes policiers
n'ont aucune formation sur la question
autochtone ben c'est ce qui décourage
c'est ça que découragerait penser que ça
ce serait ça se serait inscrit dans un
tour de réflexe normal des organisations
policières
maintenant lyon ils sont restés sur la
notion de crise cela promet choses se
couper d'un début j'ai une sorte d' est
l'indifférence
à l'échelle canadienne et québécoise
l'action se rejoint sur l'aide au drame
qui s'est joué
camille se répèterait là tu pleurais je
l'expliquais aux policiers regardez la
réserve indienne
regardez là c'est pas naturel ça ça
vient pour monde naturellement a été
créée par des politiques fédérales
s'étaient créés par des lois a été créée
par des lois racistes
c'est le résultat du racisme c'est
l'apartheid et la démolition déjà
regardé ces gens qui souffrent
regardez ces gens qui boivent qui
prennent la drogue regardez ces gens
démoli c'est le résultat aujourd'hui
pour monde comme ça ils entendaient oui
oui monsieur
c'est sûr qu'elle est sur l'histoire et
quand même l'histoire dans les airs et
elle expliqué que
que le canadien soit un citoyen canadien
que la loi sur les indiens la question
des femmes indiennes qui ne sont plus d
un viol et des ti métis qui sont des
indiens et métis qui sont pas des
indiens la dévalorisation des modes de
vie la dévaluation des langues des
cultures
puis les ravages de l'alcool mais vous
comme vous les avez fait tous les post
it en dépôt spin celle que d'autres
jouets ou senti qu est ce que t es pas
évident c'est il-76 les plus hypes
l'école est plus utilisé cette île et
grc et ceci le toujours été un endroit
très très dur très très durs notamment
sur le champignon
ce nouvel e compagnie c'était un village
de pêcheurs s'étaient d'échelle humaine
en 1950 55 kgs en l'espace de dix ans et
passe à 40000 personnes avec des rousses
de beaucoup de salaire et il ya eu un
racisme je dirais dures violences
physiques
à cette exclusion titre ça nous rappelle
le sud des états unis
exclusion d un design aux hôtels des
indiens qui se battent parce qu'il parle
à ces abus des personnes abusées femmes
cette heure actuellement mort de
personnes aussi conflit dans tous les
domaines penny vision aussi très
vicieuse de la part des gens à l'époque
que les indiens bête ou ou qu'il faisait
rien que ce départ est ce que c est là
le vrai racisme nous a fait 25 ans que
je dénonce ça ça y parvenir c'est assez
frustrant qu'on écrit dans les journaux
on écrive des lib comparé à la radio on
veut faire des conférences pour
s'aperçoit qu'à société n'est pas prête
à recevoir l'urgence de l'urgence d'agir
ça va prendre combien tu vas morte
combien tu fais c'est mais ça prendrait
quoi mais je sais pas je n'ai pas de
réponse pour vous quand on arrive aux
oubliés de l'époque d'aidé dédié suicide
collectif pour labrador je sais pas
normal c'est pas normal
et puis ça passait comme une nouvelle
simple
cette opacité c'est une société encore
eu cinq suicides un maillot tenable dans
la dernière année
c'est pas normal et mais on lui a laissé
aller normalement je me souviens très
bien cette période les suisses et blogs
déco des policiers qu'ils abandonnaient
voulez puis a laissé peu de temps de la
police autochtone qui voulait pas qu'ils
quittaient cabane en europe
quand on dit plus faire un film trouvera
un film de fiction le policier qui vient
remettre c'est son uniforme qui dit moi
je peux faire la police ici je suis
capable de décrocher dépend du jeu mais
ça tue pas aussi une autre sud à ce que
je sache qu'on garde la télévision
actuellement c'est séraphin il n'y a pas
de téléséries leur est pas dramatique
n'y a pas de c'est pas notre culture
c'est bon a noté un faux c'est pas dans
nos gènes et m
c'est pas au calendrier politique de
l'urgence il faut que les femmes parlent
les enfants parlent vite y aime pas puis
qu'ensuite la société disent ça suffit
on s'en occupe a brillé
écoutez j'ai de toute ma vie les
entrevues aux médias sur des crises
autochtone candiac crise autochtone je
le sais que téléphone beau soleil mais à
l'église autochtone c'est un peu ça que
je pense qu'ils te le début de réponse
c'est un début de réponse ça arrive aux
autochtones arrive pour nous autres